you know my friends doris burke and
jessica mendoza and
we've seen this evening has been matched
by auburn
the bounce bad second half has spilled
over into this game
i would agree talented freshman i
do think they've got to get better
offensively may have one in him tonight
by the time it's all said and done
attacking all the experiences the
camaraderie the chemistry
you know great possession cooper with
the takeaway
film that bruce pearl talks about and he
understands winning plays and that
i know arkansas staff was worried about
their team's confidence
there's nothing wrong with desi in
cooper third made shot of the last
couple of ball games five in white
and his guys motivated with no seed to
play for
no standing to play for transition
defense for
both of those these bruce pearl feeds
his guys with so much confidence as a
shooter
here is cooper to the left into the lane
talked about impacting the game in
different ways
the hogs flexing their muscles
look at a lot
deep change course this evening just one
of 16 from downtown
he should but if he can get himself
going defensively
offense will come possession
we'll see if kentucky can capitalize on
it
[Applause]
[Music]
johnson a strong finish give him 12.
the head ask me again flanagan
benefits cooper right created the loose
ball and
then johnson was there
nice this year and it's a big deal to
pick up those quad one wins
well think about this eight years old
playing
he has been solid so far jaylen tate is
really a ball hawking defender
cooper able to split the double he just
kind of is calm
you know you can tell he's an older guy
brooks hedges on cooper he goes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
you got a great size
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
michael is german
[Applause]
number two
is
[Applause]